and now it's my honor to invite on stage
madame ursula von der lion president of
the european commission
[Applause]
welcome to lugano
president zielenski
president cassis
many thanks for hosting this fantastic
conference here
prime minister shmi haldia dennis it's
wonderful to see you again
speaker of the parliament the rada mr
stefan shook also good to see you again
dear prime minister
fiala as
presidency of the european union dear
prime minister simon knight
you hosted last year the conference
prime ministers
ministers excellencies honorable guests
one month ago
a young ukrainian hero died on the
battlefield
as he fought for the future of his
country
his name was roman ratushni
and he would have turned
25
tomorrow
roman belonged to a new generation of
young ukrainians
as a teenager he was among the first
protesters
on the maidan
demonstrating for europe and for the
democracy
and ever since roma never stopped
fighting for a better ukraine
he fought for a corruption-free ukraine
both as activist and journalist
he fought for a greener ukraine
leading the movement to save a natural
park in kiev
from illegal constructions financed by
oligarchs
he fought for
sovereign ukraine
and he paid the ultimate price for it
roman's life was taken too early
but his dreams live on
the dream of a new ukraine
not only free democratic and european
but also green and prosperous
a place that ukrainians golden
generation can finally feel their own
it is this dream
that brings us here
today
because with our support
our ukrainian friends can rebuild
ukraine not just as it was but as its
young people want it to be
i know that this may sound overly
ambitious
as russian bombs keep falling
shattering not only schools and
hospitals
but also countless lives
but all of us know by now
that nothing is impossible to the brave
people of ukraine
you have just heard the determination in
the words of president zelinski
and we will soon listen to the details
of the plan from prime minister smihal
we know ukraine's immense potential
for positive change
we know it because we have seen it
affirmed time and again
since the maidan revolution eight years
ago
ukraine
has progressed visibly since february
2014 when the revolution of dignity
began
it was the only country in eastern
europe
to pass legislation to reign in
the oligarchs powers
or take the reform of the administration
and decentralization
it is a success
we see it
that the administration does function
despite this atrocious war
and this is also true for digitalization
with europe's support ukraine has
created state-of-the-art
e-government services
and an impressive cyber security machine
decentralization and digitalization have
made ukraine stronger
and this experience
how reforms work
will be precious for the reconstruction
of ukraine
because ukraine will need courageous
reforms
but reforms should go hand in hand with
investment
we all know the scale of destruction is
staggering
and costs are rising with each day of
this senseless war
this is also true
for social costs
victims
veterans
women
children
they are coming back from exile that is
good
but ukraine will have to care for them
ukraine will have to restore business
confidence
and attract more capital from abroad
ukraine will have to improve living
standards for its citizens
and ukraine will advance on its path
towards the european union
the challenges are huge without any
question
but they are not insurmountable
ukraine can emerge from this war
on a path towards a stronger
and more modern country
with a modernized judiciary
with stronger institutions
with a solid track record to fight
against corruption
but also with a greener
more digital
and more resilient economy
this is the country that so many
ukrainians
like roman
ratios are dreaming of
and fighting for
and this is why we are here today
the task ahead of us is colossal as
president zielinski said
all of you here in the room and many
more elsewhere on the screens
want to support and help re
build ukraine
and this is not only in our interest
it's also in our interest
but it is also our moral duty our moral
obligation
and this is why
the european commission has proposed to
the government of ukraine
to set up a reconstruction platform
to map investment needs
to coordinate action
to channel resources
and of course in support of an ambitious
reform agenda
this platform will be the place to shape
strategic orientations and priorities
for our common work
to focus
on future proof reconstruction
moving towards climate neutrality
embracing the digital decade
building a social market economy that
leaves no one behind
ensuring security and defense
and all of it embedded in good
governments
ukraine will be in the lead
because our action
will be driven by the aspirations and
the desires of the ukrainian people that
is so important
the platform will bring together
countries institutions the private
sector and civil society
our partners from around the globe from
switzerland
to the united states
european and international organizations
from the european bank for
reconstruction and development
that is already working in ukraine and i
really commend you for that
to the european investment bank
from the imf
to the world bank
and of course it will involve business
and business associations with all their
incredible know-how we need that
know-how we need that expertise
just recently in davos prime minister
mihal and me we have seen the keen
interest of companies and entrepreneurs
to get involved in the reconstruction of
ukraine
the platform will be open to everyone
everyone who cares
about the future of ukraine
ladies and gentlemen
europe has a special responsibility
and a strategic interest to be at
ukraine's side every step of the way
ukraine wants to be part of our european
union and we want ukraine to become a
member of the european union
ukraine is highly motivated to work with
us
in this direction
and we will do our utmost to support
these efforts
because the path towards a stronger
ukraine
and the path
of european integration
are one and the same
through the reconstruction platform the
european commission can offer extensive
expertise in running programs that
combine reform and investments
and in addition
we've been working very closely with
ukraine for a long long time
and this work will only intensify
now that ukraine has formally become a
candidate country to join our european
union
this prime minister smihal and
chairman stefan shook is your applause
it was your job your work you've done it
so from my part to many many groups
[Applause]
but of course besides our own expertise
we would like to bring in external
expertise and external advice
and thus
chancellor olav schultz and i in very
close cooperation with our international
we have never done it at that scale
before so that we can ensure
that this generational undertaking
is done
in the right way
we have a huge opportunity we should use
it
and if we have a good plan if we have a
sound plan if we have a comprehensive
plan this will give the necessary
confidence to all investors
it will give them the message your money
not only serves a good cause it does
serve a good cause
but it will be first and foremost spent
efficiently
and effectively with a maximum impact
for the benefit of the people of ukraine
the kremlin's goal
is the military
political
and economic destruction of ukraine
they want to undermine ukraine's very
existence as a state
we cannot and we will never let that
happen
since the beginning of the war
we have all mobilized the european union
for example has mobilized around about
6.2 billion euros in financial support
and as you know
more has to come and more welcome we're
fully aware that for the immediate
relief there is money flow there is
budget support necessary no now
we will engage substantially but here in
this room we also have to engage
substantially in the mid and long term
reconstruction
and here in lugano
the lugano principles
are the first important building block
guiding our way president cassis once
again many thanks for making that
possible this is the foundation from
which on we are working now to rebuild
and reconstruct ukraine the lugano
principles
i want to commend you and i want to
thank you for organizing this conference
ladies and
gentlemen we can
never match
the sacrifices
ukrainians are making every single day
ukraine's youth
is giving their life
to turn vision into reality
they are fighting for free and
independent ukraine
they are fighting for the respect of
international law and our values
so we know that their fight
is also our fight
and while we work in these days
to help ukraine to win this world
we must also make sure that ukraine
wins the peace
that will come for sure slava ukraine
thank you very much
thank you modern president van der lion
thank you very much the czech republic
has said the presidency of the european
union since the 1st of july
and now i'm delighted to welcome on
stage
mr petr fiala prime minister of the
czech republic welcome to lugano
[Applause]
mr president presidents prime ministers
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for the invitation
and for the opportunity to address you
we meet here in lugano for the fifth
time
as in previous year this year we planned
to talk about helping ukraine with
reforms and would bring it even closer
to western community what about good
governance based
of the rule of law
instead
we are here to talk about defense of
ukraine
and reconstruction
the reconstruction
of a country that
until february 24th this year
was functioning normally was prospering
and working for a better life of its
people
part of the country was already occupied
but ukraine was not threatening anyone
and was not attacking
anyone
then came february 24th and a russian
attack
europe changed
i think i am not the only one who would
wake up every night since that day to
see whether kiev
is still standing and it's independent
at the beginning many of us didn't
believe
that it could become reality
kiev
thanks to president zelinski's
leadership
has defended itself
and most of ukraine as well
vladimir zelensky
dennis mihal and their team gave people
courage
and they will to fight every day
when i arrived in kiev on march the 15th
together with prime ministers of poland
and slovenia
at that time there was
still
a curfew checkpoints and roadblocks
everywhere
then i understood the reason
why the city had not fallen
every ukrainian i met
showed determination and the will to
fight for their freedom
this only reinforced my beliefs that we
must not leave ukraine without help
my country czech republic started
supplying arms to ukraine even before
the war we continue to do so today and
we will continue to supply them in the
next weeks and months
on the territory of our country three
hundred and seventy thousand ukrainian
women children and elderly have found
refuge
more than three and a half percent of
our population
on july the 1st the czech republic took
over the presidency of the council of
the european union
the original priorities we had a few
months ago
are now significantly changed we had to
respond to the war
so a support for ukraine its post-war
reconstruction
and also managing the refugee wave
became the number one priority
these three aspects are closely linked
in order to rebuild we must help ukraine
to defend itself we must continue
supplying arms humanitarian aid but also
money for day-to-day
operations
in order for ukraine to defend itself
its defender must be sure that their
women and children are safe
that is why we are talking about
managing the refugee wave
to be frank i
don't know when the full reconstruction
of ukraine can start but i know
however that we must be prepared
we can already start repairing some of
the destroying destroyed towns so that
people can return home we can already
see people returning to their homes
every day and we must make it easier for
them
two weeks ago
ukraine and moldova achieved eu
candidate status this was a clear signal
that we are counting on these countries
that we will
not release them
it is obvious that the substantial part
of reconstruction will be on the
shoulders of the european states and
european union as such
this is natural
we must show leadership but we must also
working with others with all g7
countries with the united nations with
the world bank this and this
international monetary fund and other
international institutions
we must simply involve the whole
civilized world in the future
reconstruction of ukraine
that is why i promise that we will
cooperate as much as possible with the
european commission
and the european parliament during our
presidency of the eu council
we have no easy task
ahead of us
but we will not let ukraine down
and
i am convinced
that
even europe
will
emerge from this crisis
stronger
safer
and more resilient
thank you very much
thank you very much prime minister fiala
and now i have the great pleasure to
call on stage an honor guest from
ukraine thank you for being here
another guest from ukraine who is here
in person
please welcome mr denis mial prime
minister of ukraine
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
advisory
is
thank you very much prime minister mihal
and now i'll hand over to the moderator
yves de corps for the presentation
plenary mr ibdakar is the chairman of
the edgelands institute bonjour
bienvenue